that FTX thing is crazy because so many
people were spokespeople for it
is
you know what's funny is I got like
Bamboozled by my own trick so like back
when I was in the nft space like we
bought a billboard so people would be
skeptical about the company because nfts
and stuff and so they wouldn't be sold
on buying an nft before the drop and
then we'd pay for a New York City
billboard and because we bought a
billboard in New York City in Times
Square then it people would be like oh
it's legit now we'll buy in and I was
like what is this logic like don't you
want to buy in because of the project
and what we're building not because of
like we got we bought a billboard so I
thought that was stupid and then I
looked at FTX and I saw they had like an
arena and Tom Brady spoke for them and I
was like oh they must be legit and then
now that they collapsed I'm like wow I'm
a [ __ ] I'm a dumbass like yeah I fell
for my own trick yeah talking about
innovators groundbreakers look at this
telling you all these [ __ ] barely
making people Matt Damon fans who almost
adventured who almost achieved
But ultimately
for them it proved to be too much
are these [ __ ] losers we're talking
about people who embrace the mode that
guy's not embracing mode that guy's a
crazy [ __ ] climbing up Glacier that's
not smart this is cheesy the Wright
brothers
mere mortals oh
it's funny those guys admitted flight
and climbed them out and they're like
these
the Romans fortune favors the brave
wow it's not really braved by crypto
well it is now no but that's what
marketing does it makes you feel
something I'm gonna feel Brave and put
my money into this it's so funny because
when you keep your crypto in an exchange
it's not even yours for a person who's
not in a crypto I guess it's the
equivalent of keeping your money in like
a bank or some [ __ ] where realistically
like the bank is only is only liable for
keeping a certain amount of your money
like if it goes under like you could
just get [ __ ] over but if you have
like cold Hard Cash like that's your
money you know what I mean yes that's
like the best analogy I could give to
people so like but it's a lot riskier
with crypto because exchanges multiple
exchanges have just gone under it it's
really risky but the thing is you know
you could keep that cash digitally you
just have a hard wallet where you could
actually own your own crypto okay you
know so much more about it I I don't I I
wish I could have an intelligent
conversation with you about it I can't
what bothers me is that the government
is trying to get into crypto and into
digitizing all of our currency and they
would be able to have complete control
over our money and if you started to get
out of hands you know what happens next
shut it down shut what down government
could shut you down if they have
complete digital control over our
currency if they make occurrence if they
make a crypto and then they want to yeah
if we're in a cash world and you're
Scrooge McDuck and you have a big giant
vat full of money that you go swimming
in and that's how the world runs the
government can't come they could yes by
force come and take it but truly it's
much harder than if you all of your
money is digital and they have complete
control over over the banking and the
digital currency and they can literally
just with a button shut down people who
they don't want doing certain or saying
certain things you know what I love is
that this is just a show of people that
dudes just like ripping beers and cigars
and people just like listen to them talk
like me and my friends do this all the
time we just rip beers and we just shoot
[ __ ] but then millions of people watch
these guys do it yeah it's [ __ ]
hilarious that's what we're doing now
except I'm ripping tequila and you're
just drinking coffee because you're
Bernard but with something like that FTX
thing goes down where you watch billions
of dollars just disappear yeah I lost a
fortune
the fortune favors the Braves are we
doing that with that well I'm just
saying I lost a lot of money this guy
yeah these guys are stoned and drunk
they're having a great time I thought
you were joking no no I lost a ton how
much
I don't want to get into numbers here at
being impolite how much
but uh enough to disturb you indeed that
was the first time I checked I lost like
15 grand in the tens like this year yeah
wow I thought it was rookie numbers
buddy get your numbers up I was never
gonna take it out of there so people are
suing Larry David yeah commercial
because he did a commercial for them
they're suing there's a class action
lawsuit I think it involves uh
find out what it does Tom Brady Larry
David
I don't know that it's going through yet
I think they've talked about it okay if
you can't take enough personal
accountability to be like oh I shouldn't
have listened to Larry David and what to
do with my crypto you're a dumbass yeah
there's that okay first of all second of
all I would I would like to think that
Larry David Tom Brady Matt Damon's
um you know what do you call it
contracts have them completely protected
by from any lawsuits so they you know
they they have complete immunity oh yeah
whatever company it was that hired them
is going to be protecting them legally
it's not going to cost them anything
that I'm not worried about them at all
and if for the schmuckers that are suing
them like they were just paid actors and
we all know it's an advertisement it
could have been some random Joe schmoe
actor doing it too that you've never
seen his face before you're gonna sue
him too put his wife and kids in the
poor house because he finally got an
acting job get me like what again people
or people suck people suck you're right
take some personal responsibility you
got the Feeling fortune favors the brave
I'm brave I'll put every last dollar I
have into this without doing all the due
diligent research because Larry David
told me to [ __ ] you and your lawsuit I
can't I can't stand how litigious this
country has become and this world has
become but then there's also the people
that are like where's my money yeah and
this guy is just gonna go to some bad
times legit thing that they're doing
this week right
where's my money yeah they've got some
New York Times thing where people are
speaking Yeah and he's going to go up
there hey I [ __ ] up
dude
that's probably gonna be very important
yes
I think it was over collateralized it
was over collateralized
this guy literally at one point said I
take responsibility because I should
have probably been more aware of X Y and
Z and it really pissed me off positions
that fall substantial size and
substantial US dollar size
this is nuts it looks like Oz
right I don't like it don't look fast
couldn't get this guy a better plants
put the headphones on so you can hear
this guy
no it's bizarre was consistent bizarre
Jewish
um I would go yay what are you talking
about foreign
it but you would agree yeah much look at
him shaking we connected
um I think he just shakes of FTX
International bro he's tricky and
previously understood
yeah look at the pupils are huge I mean
given the size of the position I think
it was like it's not in intention it was
in effect uh tied together substantially
more than I would have ever wanted it to
be this is weird
claiming ignorance in in some instances
too to a certain I didn't know laws that
he broke I didn't know I didn't know
about anything I didn't know about the
the money in the back I didn't do
anything with development I didn't do I
didn't know it's like what do you know
how how dare you run that much money
without knowing about about the rules of
the game you know it's one thing so like
you say you get arrested for jaywalking
in a new city and you go I'm so sorry
like I moved from X City where
jaywalking is not a problem and not a
crime to hear and I didn't know I my
apologies you know can I please have
some Grace this one time that's one
thing it's a small thing it's nobody got
hurt you know assuming uh but but this
guy claiming ignorance when you're
running a multi-billion dollar font and
your control you're ruining lives and
controlling elections I mean there's a
lot of that all the money that he was
giving and you know to all these causes
[ __ ] you Sam from the rest of us
anything like that Alameda is a wholly
separate entity they're different
offices like different principal offices
we don't have any shared Personnel we're
also not the same company we not all are
under the same corporate umbrella or
anything like that and yet it seems
like Alameda people were living in the
same Penthouse it's so funny right now I
guess it seems that way doesn't it
[ __ ] wow yeah right um uh most of
Alameda was not uh was not there uh I I
don't live there now but uh or not there
now I have not
skinny arm but you know I did live with
with uh one or two members [ __ ] is this
plant that's a good point what is that
thing that's a crappy looking plant
sorry plant no offense this is the best
they could come up with it's probably a
it's probably a twenty thousand dollar
piece of artwork or more probably a
fifteen hundred dollar chair
also say that you know as I was you know
earlier this poor little freak came at
the relationship and this is what a dude
it's really autistic
I can't recognize my own fish
yeah he's tweaking out like Hitler
tweaking out yes that got a lot of
pressure very Under Pressure also the
most pressure tweaking from that for
sure imagine billions of dollars I'm
missing gone yeah that's live dude he's
getting billions billions and you know
they're they've got like all these
tweets and [ __ ] different things that
they've said in different statements
that he said about his company that just
seemed to be untrue live updates of the
stuff he was saying during it too uh but
the thing that he was just discussing
there was this another company called
Alameda and apparently they gave in
they'd move 10 billion dollars over to
Alameda and they don't know like how
that was done or what it was done but it
was like a company that was connected to
them initially he lied about it and said
he didn't work with those people and
they were all banging each other they
were living in the same house
that was last week
he's gone yeah they had he lived in a
house with like 10 people they were all
banging each other influence every time
Bitcoin every time and they were all
doing amphetamines this lady who was one
of them was on she wrote on Twitter this
was like one of the times
on Twitter that after you what was the
exact quote we talked about yesterday
you've heard that you've heard about
this before Oh that oh the girl who who
supposedly was like I'm bad at math and
was running and it was like ahead of
compliance or Finance or something yeah
I've seen her oh my God I'm sorry uh
that's something that is I just went
it looks like fried is [ __ ] damn fried
he looks like he's [ __ ] the way that
wasn't great I didn't understand one
word I don't remember freed rather as
[ __ ]
free describes to make you appreciate
how dumb a lot of normal non-medicated
human experiences this is in April 2021
nothing like regular amphetamine used to
make you appreciate that time about a
normal
reaction which we just saw she was one
of the top dogs over there
she was one of the top people over there
and they were all banging each other
every time
banging each other making
take the money away from the people I
don't know what happened man but whoa
yeah that was chamberlains 40 million
dollar Penthouse and now it's listed for
sale
good for them yeah but they know how
those movies end they're pushing half
soft dicks into each other
yeah man I wish because if it wasn't a
Ponzi scheme that's like their branding
for FTX really was so phenomenal you got
it like for them to pull that off it's
it's crazy to look at The Branding they
had was so clean simple I honest like
I'm being serious like they're they're
good branding is what got them so far
like it was just looked at as such a
like an accredited exchange like I would
have never guessed I'd also I'm not like
a super crypto geek I don't look into
that [ __ ] but I wouldn't have guessed
something like that
would have happened it's [ __ ] Madness
it is madness it is madness how tricks
we can be by marketing too on top of the
media yeah and you know what for the
Larry David and the and the Tom Brady
and the the Matt Damon they were also
fooled so anyone that's suing them as if
they weren't fooled their job is acting
and uh throwing a football and you know
whatever producing Larry David they they
shouldn't have to you know they're not
Financial experts and to sue them they
were full too they're also their faces
attached to some really scandalous [ __ ]
now and it's it's not cool it's not cool
for them either so we need it they need
a little sympathy too anyone that's
suing that needs a punch in the face all
right guys I'll see you later yes I'm
hurting I don't know what to say what to
say hey